you tweeted that you aspired to comedy
you're friends with joe rogan
might you uh do a short stand-up comedy
set at some point in the future
maybe um open for joe something like
that is that is that really up actual
just blown stand up full-on stand-up is
that in there or is that i've never
thought about that
um it's extremely difficult if
at least that's what the like joe says
and the comedians say
huh i wonder if i could um i mean one
way to find out
you know i i have done stand up for
friends just uh
impromptu
you know i'll get get on like a roof uh
and they
they do laugh but they are friends too
so
i don't know if if you've got to call
you know like a rumor strangers are they
gonna actually also find it funny but
i could try
see what happens
i think you'd learn something either way
um yeah i kind of love um
both the when you bomb and when when you
do great just watching people how they
deal with it
it's so difficult it's so you're so
fragile
up there it's just you
and you you think you're gonna be funny
and when it completely falls flat it's
just it's beautiful to see people
deal with like that uh yeah i might have
enough material to do standard
no no i've never thought about but i
might have enough material um
i don't know like 15 minutes or
something oh yeah yeah do it do a
netflix special
nothing special sure
you